do you think that western governments in
particular
overreacted to the pandemic well they
first under reacted and then overreacted
i think that would be the right way to
put it but there was a way to get this
right
that averted mass death and also averted
lockdowns it was what they did in
taiwan the taiwanese who have every
reason to be suspicious of their
neighbors the people's republic of china
very quickly realized that something
wicked was coming their way from wuhan
restricted travel but more importantly
actually wrapped up testing
because it was quite easy to test for
this virus early on
sequencing the virus had proved to be
very very easy
they also had a system of integrated
contact tracing using
phones and so they were able to quickly
identify who had it and who
might have spread it and then to isolate
people who were infected and as a result
of this very rapid response
12 people a dozen have died of cove in
taiwan which is right next door to where
this thing
began so we know there was a right way
of doing this the south koreans also did
very well
there were a bunch of countries that
were quick off the mark
and were therefore able to avert
lockdowns taiwan had the least
stringent government measures of any
country when you look at the oxford
blavatnik school
stringency index so that tells us that
that what happened in the uk in the us
was clearly sub-optimal
what happened was that the public health
officials dithered around and so did the
politicians but i think we should
recognize that
ultimately sounding the alarm about a
pandemic is not the job of the prime
minister it's the job of the people
whose job it is to worry about public
health
the public health officials dithered
around at both sides of the atlantic
january february first half of april
and then another neil ferguson i want to
make it clear that i'm not here
before the hate mail begins uh the neil
ferguson at imperial college london the
epidemiologist published
a paper mid-march saying if we don't
lock down
and he could have said like the chinese
who by that time had completely shut
everything down
if we don't log down we're going to have
half a million dead people in britain
and we're going to have 2.2 million dead
in the u.s
and politicians read this and thought oh
god
we better do this we better shut
everything down so there were
extraordinary measures taken uh from
mid-march onwards
like sheltering place orders here in
california locking people in their homes
because the initial opportunity to shut
the virus down had been missed
uh and then i think you can have a
debate about whether the lockdowns were
overkill uh and i think many respects
they were but what you can't i think say
is that we should have done nothing at
that point because by that point we
really had got ourselves into a serious
mess with
with the virus spreading rapidly all
across the us and all across
and all across europe we had to do
something i think we did more things
than we needed to
because those look downs were a very
very blunt instrument
and we also of course uh couldn't really
follow neil ferguson's
advice because he said you have to do
this until there are vaccines
now nobody in their right mind
could have locked down the u.s or uk
economy
for the entire period that it took to
get the vaccines available
and so what we did was we locked down
and then we realized we'd completely
created the economy we had to start
lifting restrictions and then play
whack-a-mole with re-infections
so looking back on it this was a pretty
big public policy failure to say that it
was going to be
a failure at the time was hard but i was
writing a weekly column back in those
days for the sunday times
and i do remember thinking that
ultimately we'd gone from
too little to too much and that that
that ensured we had lots of mortality
but also
huge economic and social disruption
definitely the worst of both worlds